olá
bom pessoal hoje o vídeo não vai ser
aquela que eu estava à espera que fosse
porque porque hoje estou um tempo mais
doente torcedores cabeça tudo sentir
aquela sina de gripe sabem que o mal
estar gritando tá doer já tem aqui o
descumprimento esperando que os
comprimidos conectam já vencendo com os
complementos mas tenho dois comprimidos
e tomar banho é grande e eu não consigo
globo cana está a cumprir este já tem
uma postura de maluco de uma pastilha de
ajuda foi bom e também dura até mastigar
castanho dois comprimidos por tomar ao
sambar grande não vou conseguir a
polícia automáticas para ver se passa
hoje não vai ser o vídeo conta mais para
vocês que eu cheguei aqui de manhã cedo
para começar a gravar mas foi quando
este começou a equipa do e do jogo saiu
uma estrada de micro no litotal porcaria
do mcdonald e hoje comentou assim sobe
começar o ataque minha sopa eu nem
colher pegue o país com uma palhinha
memória assim a canalha hoje a sugeira
[ __ ] começou passei muito difícil por
acaso o tal eo bpi também não vinha de
nove mil inscritos
a opção do ibope que chegou a 19 mil
inscritos não foi bem comenta
hoje o tempo é igual à tarde para dizer
que o fim roberto estranho contou assim
mas eu nunca fiquei assim eu só fico uma
vez por ano e mas quando o engraçado
porque é uma o corpo é por isso que eu
vou fazer este vídeo por sua mãe ia
acontecer alguma coisa se não houver o
vídeo assim vocês já sabem por que eu
fiquei mesmo mal mas eu vou tentar que
saiu por aí mesmo que esteja mal eu vou
tentar fazer como fazer hoje tipo pra
vocês não fiquem sem vídeo que eu não
quero isso mas agora um vídeo pia cara
parece uma cena é que na garganta
olá eu estava muito ruinzinho deve
anunciar tudo ok um go onyx médio mas
que trouxe média 600 médio
o tac os complemente obrigado ainda mais
fofo
agora temos alguns complementos é uma
missão impossível porque olham também
desta ou estético motor gêmeas ou quem
inteiro né mas será agora pessoal e novo
eu vou pedir para tratar assim agora
preciso de uma 3 compreende o sample ao
fundo confundi lo sob do mal
a cantata 1 já tava pra tomar banho nele
muitas vezes não consigo comer com
primitivo não da mota tem 23 22 horas no
jardim eu já tentei tomar cumprimento
com banana e com pão e não não deixe eu
e se eu souber que tem lá um comprimido
eu não deves vai no país foi xico embora
não da [ __ ] coisa grande
só quer sócios que se o comprimido que
eu escolhi a vossa opinião porque eu
agora não ter mesmo vídeo por dia e
vocês têm apoiado pra [ __ ] muito
obrigado mesmo bege eu cansei assim é
ter um pouquinho de falta de ideias ti
quais são os jogos que vocês querem ver
eu vou começar a trazer outra vez aqui
né e tb vou começar a fazer assim mais
coisas desse gênero e investigar o site
assim mas jogos de cortar tibô escasso e
não consigo encontrar jogos bons é não
ser este fragmento fred que está a ser
agora sobre se tornou a [ __ ] nenhuma
por isso vocês também algum jogo assim
um bacana nem posso comentar isso que eu
vá imaginam vou jogar já com boa cabeça
e se eu começar a buscar ainda vai doer
mais por isso só mais lá para amputados
da próxima semana a partir daí quarta ou
quinta
para começar a fazer assim obrigado com
o feedback beijo na bunda e nenhum